it's almost like it's not news that our
banking system is collapsing I wake up
it's 6 a.m I look at my phone and I'm
like my eyes are like stuck shut and I'm
like what's going on here I look at my
phone and it's like the federal
government seized First Republic Bank
this morning and sold it to JP Morgan
with 50 billion dollars in financing
from them and I'm like wait what at four
in the morning they did this wow it
sounds like it's all falling apart and
then throughout the rest of the day like
no one's talking about the first thing I
saw was your Tweet and I was like oh we
got to write about this right away that
was our first story out today and
everyone was like oh wow how about that
you guys hear vices going bankrupt it's
like dude our banking system is bankrupt
yeah oh yeah but Vice sucks that's also
true I mean look our banking system
sucks too our banking system also sucks
I don't I I guess the issue is like we
know the banks are failing but what do
we do I feel like exactly I feel like
everybody that's kind of like the
situation everyone knows everyone's
aware of how much money has been printed
in the past five years how much money
they printed it was you know
unprecedented amounts of money